foreign
hey Heather welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me hey thanks
for calling how can we help
well I'm in an interesting position
where my ex-husband is dying of cancer
he just was notified last week that he
maybe has
about a month to live
so I'm so sorry Heather
yeah thank you
um
so he and I when we were married we both
put got term life insurance speak
directly into your phone Heather we're
having a hard time hearing you
I'm sorry is this any better that's
better thank you okay uh-huh sorry so we
have uh term life insurance policies and
I am the beneficiary of his policy
because we do have two children together
and I guess my question is when he
passes should I anticipate that I will
pay for his funeral with that money even
if I'm not permitted to
um Planet because I'm you know because
we're divorced or what I'm I guess I'm
wondering like what should I maybe
anticipate who else would would be
involved with the planning
um his mom and and dad he's currently
living with his mom and stepdad and so
they'll probably head up the planning
but his dad and stepmom are also around
and
and may be able to help pay for that I'm
not sure do you know anything about
their financial situation
um I know that his mom and stepdad uh
are not they make a lot of money but
they spend it all and his dad has been
very good at saving and is worth
probably a couple million dollars oh wow
okay so what are your kids ages
they're six and nine
and how much is the term life insurance
it's for 750 000.
okay have you had any conversations with
family and his parents regarding the
funeral arrangements
not yet I've inquired with him
and a matter
but
um he's not doing well so his
communication his ability to communicate
is limited and so I'm just wanting to
know that I guess get your opinion like
if they come to me saying well he has
his life insurance why should we pay for
it then I kind of have an idea of how I
should respond my best
um
yeah as far as your legal obligation I
don't think you have one
um as far as the relational piece of
this equation and emotionally and the
kids being involved and the parents
being involved
um you know the funeral would probably
cost how much do you think fifteen
thousand
that's what I'm guessing yeah okay
um it could be lower depending on the
situation in your area but I would at
least start to get a picture of what
that looks like and start talking to
family about it you don't want any of
this to be a surprise and have people
angry when you're already grieving this
wild loss
so my next step would be to at least if
you can't communicate with him
communicate with the family and say hey
what what would the next steps be how do
we want to handle this
well and and for sure starting with the
conversation it's a hard conversation to
have obviously but then you know just
kind of depending on that how that
conversation goes I would settle in your
own Spirit beforehand that you may end
up paying for it and that's okay because
I know a lot of times with funerals
emotions are high I have heard of so
many funeral situations where families
get in big fights over money and they
end up not talking and it just gets
really really messy and given that you
do have the money
um I would just settle if you do have to
pay for it for the kids sake for your
own peace of mind I would just not allow
the the money behind the funeral to
break things down
okay and another option is just to go
hey can we all split this evenly with
the immediate family I want to use this
money to help set our the kids up for
financial success whether that's paying
for college paying off debts that we
have as I continue raising them and so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
you stating those facts
are you in a good financial situation
um mediocre I don't I have just a little
bit of debt I'm trying to pay but
um I
don't we rent it's just me and my two
kids and
um I haven't had any financial support
from him there's a lot since we've been
divorced so okay so there hasn't been
any ongoing child support alimony
no he hasn't been able to work
wow it's a messy situation but I mean I
and this is just we you know a lot of
times when we're in these situations
it's like if I were in your shoes I
would protect the piece in my home at
all costs I mean not at all costs you
have 750 000 but if it costs the funeral
expenses I would make sure that my peace
of mind the Peace of Mind of my children
is that they're protected as someone who
lost a father to cancer at seven years
old I know that having my mom be able to
feel peace through that situation really
helped my brother and I and I think if
there was huge turmoil among the family
and there were a lot of arguments that
would have made it 10 times harder on us
so obviously we talk about money here
money is important being strategic with
your money is important but this is also
a highly emotional situation and I would
not allow this situation to break down
the relationship with your children's
grandparents I wouldn't allow this
situation to be something that you know
causes a lot of strife and Discord and
turmoil and family and make sure that
there is a will that is in place signed
that's up to date go over it with the
family it's not a fun thing to do but
it's going to prevent a lot of
relational turmoil down the road and if
there's an executor of that will that
would be who would traditionally take
care of the funeral arrangements and
potentially pay for it but again there's
no there's no real heart in fact rule
against around that so this is going to
be some hard conversations and I'd be
prepared to pay for it like Christina
said and it's a small part of that life
insurance and it's one of the reasons we
tell people to get it in place because
it takes the financial stress out of
something that is already so difficult
to deal with yeah and it's just a good
reminder for anyone listening to really
think through those end of life
situations I know it's not a fun
conversation to have it's kind of scary
it's kind of sticky but making sure you
have term life insurance making sure
that you have a will done so that your
family doesn't have to stress and go
through a bunch of strife if you you do
pass that's just good to handle